الخبر الثاني من نفس عالم الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا مثير جدا للجدل ايضا وهذه
المره متعلق بالروبوتات فمجلس بلديه سان
فرانسيسكو صوت على تبني قرار بالسماح
لعناصر شرطتها باستخدام روبوتات قادره على
القتل والنيه استخدامها في حالات هجمه
الارهابيه او عمليات القتل الجماعه كيف
الشرطه
المتحكم فيها عن بعد يعني والقرار الجديد
بين النصف على تزويد هذه الروبوتات بعبوات
ناسفه او غير عن الاسلحه اللي تعيق او
تربك اي مسلحه او مجرم رغم انه القرار
بنصف على استخدام الروبوتات في القتل في
الحالات الطارئ فقط وانه يمكن كبار عناصر
الشرطه فقط من اصدار الاوامر للروبوتات
قلنا راح تستخدم لانقاذ الابرياء لكن هذا
طبعا ابدا الجدل اللي فتحوا الموضوع ففي
وقت الشرطه والسلطه بتقول انه هذا هو الحل
الاخير امام ما في وجهه ازاي يدلف يعني
فيه ناس كمان في نفس الوقت جالسه بتهاجم
القرار تماما وشايفه انه ممكن يزيد من عنف
رجال الشرطه هذا غير النقاش طبعا المتعلق
باخلاقيه تمكين اله من القتل والناس اللي
شايفه انه استخدام للتكنولوجيا في اسوا
الصور خليني ارجع لك دكتور محمد قاسم
الاستشاري في مؤسسه الكويت للتقدم العلمي
يعني فعليا دكتور محمد ايش رايك في هذا
النوع من الروبوت القاتل
طبعا بالتاكيد هذا التوجه راح يتحقق لا
مجال للتراجع واذا ما سويت امريكا راح
تسويه الصين اذا ما سويتها راح اسوي روسيا
الدول كلها في هذا الاتجاه هو الان تساءل
هو كيف ممكن نتحكم في الموضوع بحيث انه ما
يضر البشر يعني حاليا انت على فكره
الروبوتات مستخدمه وقد استخدم روبوت في
2016 وكان ايضا معه عبوه ناسفه فاذا
بالامكان او استخدم هذا الشيء في السابق
ولكن كان في على الطيور
محمد وصلح لي هذا الشيء يعني بيستخدم
روبوتات في تفكيك المتفجرات ايضا
بالضبط تفكيك المتفجرات وايضا حتى استخدام
متفجر لانقاذ البشر فهذا الشغله ممكن تصير
لحمايه الشرطه لان احيانا وقد حدث يعني
قبل الفتره بسيطه انه شخص دخل على مدرسه
فيها طلاب والشرطه و بتصوير يعني كامل
الشرطه من خوفهم ما دخلوا على
المجرم هذا ولم يوقفوه وقتل الكثير من
الناس فهذا يعني يعطي نوع من الحمايه
للشرطه وايضا يعطي حمايه للناس اللي همم
ممكن يقتله في حاله مثل الحالات هذه فهي
شوفي يعني في نقاش كبير جدا على هذا
الموضوع لكن لا زال يعني احنا ما نقعد
نتكلم عن الذكاء اصطناعي ان الروبه مستقل
بذاته او يحمل سلاح ويرمي في كل مكان انما
العزال هناك تحكم من البشر وانا صراحه
اتمنى اذا فعلا حققه هذا الشيء انه يحطون
عليه ذكاء اصطناعي يتعرف على البشر حتى
يتاكد قبل لا يقوم همم
لي انه في وسط خصوصا لما بنتكلم ان احنا
على مثلا الاحداث ذي اللي بتحدث الهجمات
هذه اللي في المدارس والاشياء دي كده هذه
بيدخل الحامل بالنابل فيها يعني بيكون
مثلا مطلق النار بين الطلاب بين كده كيف
التمييز يصير يعني ما انت ممكن يروح عندك
ضحيه يعني كده على الماشي
ولذلك يومين قرار ان الشيف فقط هو اللي
اتخذ القرار في هذا الموضوع في ان مثلا
يرمي القنبله او حتى استخدام هذا النوع من
الروضه طبعا انا مو قاعد ادافع عنها يعني
يمكن من طريقه كلامي انا قاعد ادافع عن
روبك لا بالعكس انا اعتقد انه مثل هذه
الاشياء يجب ان تدرس لانه ما عندنا دراسات
حتى في الحرب
تستخدمونها الى صفوف الطلاب اذا صارت
حادثه من الحوادث اللي تصير عاده خصوصا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامر وايد
صعب محتاجه الى دراسه وفهم وتاكيد حتى قبل
لا نستخدم مثل هذه الاشياء اللي لم تتجرب
في السابق من قبل طيب الان لما نيجي نتكلم
في كل هذه المواضيع وحضرتك ذكر ايجابيات
والسلبيات ودائما في سؤال حول الاخلاقيه
استخدام هذه الاشياء يعني اكيد ما هنتسال
عن اخلاقيه مثلا
ينظف البيت هذا يا سلام كثير منه مثلا
يعني بس الاشياء الثانيه لا عليها علامات
استفهام كبيره مين اللي هيجيء ويجلس يتحكم
في هذا القرار نعمل او ما نعمل هل مثلا
يعني زي الماسك ما بيعمل اليوم في تويتر
مثلا
هذا السؤال جدا رائع يعني بالنسبه لهذه في
مؤسسات انا اتذكر يعني
في بعض المؤسسات موجوده في امريكا تحاول
ان تبحث في اخلاقيات هذا الموضوع حتى
تتاكد من ان ما يصير مشاكل الاخلاقيه
وللعلم يعني بس على السريع داخل نقطه انه
حتى الروبوتات اللي تنظف البيت هم فيها
اخلاقيات والناس يحبوني تاكدون قبل لا
يدخل الروضه للبيت ويؤذي مثل كبار السن
ممكن الرابط لهم عن طريق انه هو حامل سلاح
لكن حتى حمله السكين او شيء هذا ممكن
يقعدني البشر اللي موجودين المساله هذه
هناك مؤسسات شغاله على الموضوع هناك
محاولات في تشريحها الشركات نفسها ايضا
قاعده تضع مجموعه من المختصين والخبراء في
الاخلاقيات حتى يدرسوا هذا الموضوع بس
احنا لازمنا يعني قاعدين نشوف ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي او امور تكنولوجيه من هذا النوع
قاعده تسبق الاخلاق يعني احنا وبتكنولوجيا
وايد اسرع من الاخلاق اللي احنا قاعدين
نشوف همم يعني رده فعل هنا وهناك وغير
متكامله غير واضحه والتكنولوجيا تطلع ثم
بعد ذلك تعال خلينا نمسك
البعبع المرعب هذا اللي طلع في كل شيء
يعني صراحه بس سؤال سريع على هذا النوع من
المؤسسات اللي بتتحدث عنه هل هي موجوده في
العالم العربي ايضا ولا لا
المؤسسات اللي شفتها هي موجوده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في الغالب
يعني غالبا هي هناك اذن وهناك حاجه بس
احنا بنشكرك على هذا
المداخله كان معنا الدكتور محمد قاسم
الاستشاري في مؤسسه الكويت التقدم العلمي
شكرا لك دكتور
[موسيقى]